hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing our match
uh on game eight between paul charles
murphy and your hanyakov levantal uh so
far things are not looking great for
uh our good friend johan jakob as uh
this is game eight and he's losing the
match seven to one
but it's you know still early a lot a
lot can happen and here we have
one very excellent game that really
shows us how complicated and yet simple
chess
is or rather maybe i would be better to
say how simple yet complicated
seems the same but it's really not so
without further ado uh let's
check it out morphe with the white
pieces opens with e4
uh sorry about that uh we have e5 by
elemental
and we have the same line they played in
the previous game only now with colors
reverse knight f3 d6 philidor's defenses
on the board
and the d4 we have captures queen
captures and then we said the knight to
c6 was pretty much an automatic nowadays
and the morphe preferred bishop to e6
for whoever knows what reason
uh but we have bishop to d7 by eleven
thou he
uh he thinks that the bishop should be
on this diagonal and that's how he
is going to play it so morphy continues
development bishop e3
we have knight to f6 and knights to c3
now
with bishop to e7 and now bishop to c4
again continuing development a leaving
options for both castling kingside and
queen side
and it is as of move 7 that this
position has never been reached again
now we have knight to c6 finally
attacking the queen queen back to d2
and now knight e5 forcing a trade here
unless morphy is uh well
willing to go back with bishop to e2 uh
but morpheus is not a problem we're
going to trade captures captures and
here
castle's king side which is very
interesting as uh
uh leontal is most probably gonna castle
kingside
uh one would think that uh someone of uh
you know morphy style would castle queen
side here but okay
we have castles kings side castles king
side by both of them and now
f4 uh attacking this uh e5 pawn
wanting to open up some files and here
knight the g4 would put a lot of
pressure on morphy's bishop he would
have to
uh well if if uh alive intel wanted he
could win the bishop pair here however
he decides to go bishop to d6 instead
and
now morphy extends his pawn all the way
to f5
and okay bishop to c6 now with a double
attack on the e4 pawn
and queen to e2 and here morphy sets a
very very interesting trap and this is
what uh
uh what i enjoy most in morphy's games
where
it's hard to say whether his opponents
really
understood what what was happening here
but they avoided the grabbing the pawn
uh unless they're like uh thomas wilson
barnes
but that's uh that's a different story
so here what happens if you capture the
pawn
is that you get you just get annihilated
but i will show it for example knight
captures
knight captures bishop captures it seems
like you won a pawn
however queen to g4 attacks the bishop
here
and also uh something else but what do
you do here bishop captures on c2 and
now
not f6 right away uh because that just
allows the bishop to go back with bishop
to g6
first rook to f2 this is the star move
uh attacking that also rookie to c1 is
good
just attacking that bishop and not
allowing it to remain on this diagonal
guarding the g6 square
so rook f2 and now black just loses the
bishop
unless you want to move the bishop for
example bishop to a4
now comes f6 threatening checkmate g6
defending and now queen h4 with the idea
of this checkmate
and there really is no good defense here
you could try something like king h8
uh hoping to maybe get the rook in to
prevent it but it doesn't matter rook f3
comes and now the rook also joins the
party
and there is no defense against both of
these uh checkmates
and there's even a really funny
checkmate one of my favorite checkmates
for example if black uh only saw this
threat and plays rook to g8 now you can
even sacrifice your queen
and it's a very nice checkmate because
the pawn covers the g7 square
one might uh that you might want to
remember as
it uh it could happen uh very often in
your own games now that you know it
exists
so here after queen to e2 uh of course
lovanthal didn't go for the pawn
uh as he calculated everything uh and he
played h6
now just taking away the g5 square from
morphe's pieces and morphe continues
rook 8 to d1 he wants to trade a lot of
pieces on the d5 square
and doesn't want to mess up his pawn
structure so queen e7
getting the queen away from the d file
and bishop the d5 now by morphe we have
a capture fest on the d5 square captures
captures we have captures and captures
now leaving the pawn structure intact
and now at some point uh of course
leventhal will want to trade off uh the
the dark square bishops because morphy's
dark square bishop is a good bishop
he has these pawns on light scores he
can use it for attack and uh
well this bishop is not all that great
because of the e5 pawn here on a dark
square and at some point you're probably
going to play c6 kick the rook away and
trade the bishops off via bishop c5
so first f6 uh one of the positions
where it's actually okay to play f6 and
now
the queen to g4 by morphe again now you
can threaten some rook lifts rook f3
rook h3 maybe with some ideas here
uh but okay c6 pushing the rook back
rook back to d3 and now bishop to c5 of
course love intel wants to trade off the
dark square bishops with queen to g3 and
now
rook 8 d8 offering to trade everything
off and to go into a king and pawn
end game and morphy says all right rook
after d1
and now rook captures on the e3 we have
rook captures and now the tricky
rook to d8 by laurenthal uh allowing
bishop captures on c5 but
luckily uh it will come with check so
bishop captures on c5
queen captures on c5 with checks so you
will have time to trade here
queen to f2 offering a queen trade
captures with the check
captures rook captures and pawn captures
and now morphy
improved his pawn presence in the center
but lointel reacts properly now morphe
of course as he does have a backward
spawn here wants to play king to e3 push
d4
and of course low install until stops
that and now we're gonna see
uh in those days uh in 1850 um
in 1857 uh how they played
the the end game uh or or is it 1858
uh i i just had a a small blockade let
me just
check this uh yeah 1858 sorry about that
uh so here we're going to see how they
treat the king and pawn end game and
it's very interesting how they treat it
because uh well
you'll just see here morphy goes uh g4
uh which is which is which is a fine
move but uh
usually in the king opponent game you
you first want to increase your king
presence
as much as possible so here if you could
somehow reach the g6 square that'd be
great but okay
morphe goes for g4 instead we have king
to f8
and now a4 by morphe we have b6 and now
king to g3 now morphy starts bringing
his king into the game we have king to
f7 king h4
king back to f8 and now king to h5 by
morphy here we have king back to f7
and now we get this very interesting
position where elemental decided that
okay i'm not
uh allowing your king to touch the g6
square
however the position is completely lost
for black
uh but you have to pause the video and
win the game for morphe uh in order for
the game to be winning
so while i give you a couple of seconds
try and solve this position
uh you know do your thing
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on
not touching the b-pawn and for those
who if you just want to enjoy the show
it's either
h3 or h4 or even king to h4
is is possible you'll still be winning
uh but kh4 is only winning because
you will again be able to put your king
to h5 and push h3 or h4 so disregard
that move
uh but here morphy played the very
interesting b3 and this is a problem
this is a problem
if you're a beginner and you're you know
trust only starting to enjoy king and
opponent games
you do not want to squander away pawn
moves in a king and pawn end game
a pawn move when you have it and when
your opponent doesn't have it
it means everything and we're going to
show why here here uh
h3 or h4 is winning because for example
h4
black now can only wait and hopefully
not allow white to
get access to the g6 square so a6 let's
say and now morphe continues with the g5
as he prepared it
captures captures you're going to go b5
and now
just b3 or you can trade and play b3
this is why you wait to have this b3
move when you need it
uh you you could also play captures here
and then also get access to the h6
square
a lot of ideas are possible but just uh
to play this
simple b3 move captures captures and now
let's say a5
and now you're going to capture an f6 uh
so we reached the same idea only
through a different move order captures
into king to h6
and now you still need to reach the g6
square king f8 and now you're gonna go
king to g6 and after king to e7 you're
gonna go king g7
and next move your opponent doesn't have
any pawn moves uh it'd be
it'd be great if he did but he doesn't
and he will have to move the king and
you're going to start
gobbling up the pawns you're going to
create a pass pawn queen the pawn and
win the game
however morphy played b3 here and now
it's a different story so
it seems like everything is the same you
will be able to reach the g6 square even
sooner
but king f8 morphe reaches the g6 square
and now king to g8
we have h3 by morphe uh going for the
same idea with h4 now
uh shows a bit problematic for morphe
because king f8
g5 you're gonna play captures captures
and now after f captures on g5 king
captures king f7
and you again have no access to the to
the g6 square
and now you you have problems uh there's
no way
to continue and it's just going to be a
draw so here morphe tried uh
waiting on it with h3 but now comes king
to f8 with
h4 king back to g8 and now
finally g5 so everything is exactly the
same uh
but morphy spawn is already on b3
instead of on b2
as it should have been all along with h
captures captures and now
f captures and g5 king captures and king
f7
again not allowing the morphe to reach
the g6 square
so king h4 we have king to e7
and now king to g4 we have king to f6
and now
king to h5 a bit of a triangulation
party between the two of them
we have a6 preparing uh some pawn pushes
here
but just king h4 we have g6 now
offering some pawn traits and a5 by
morphe now
it's all good because uh these two
squares are covered so
it's fine we have b captures on a5 and
now
f captures on g6 king captures and king
g4 morphe gains the opposition
even though for the moment he's down
upon with a4
uh returning the pawn so b captures and
now
a5 uh now that uh
uh it's white to move white needs to
break opposition so king of three
and now king to f6 white unable to gain
opposition here
so king f2 and now king to f7 uh we have
king to g3 and now king to g7
grabbing the long opposition king of two
king of six we're having
king to g1 by morphy here
any move kingy to king f3 king g3
everything is fine for morphe but morphy
uh probably angry with himself that he
didn't win that position he probably
played that b3 move because he thought
like yeah i mean this long till dude of
course he's going to lose this whatever
i play so i'm just going to play any
move
uh but then uh got an equal position and
it's hard to say morphe was probably
angry he played king to g1
wanting to confuse love until uh even
further
but now the position is lost for morphy
so feel free to pause the video and
win the game for love until now while i
give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting the long
opposition and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it's king to g5
and now the thing is you have access to
both of these squares so you will be
able to again
again again gain opposition uh so king
g2
and now king to f4 or g4 doesn't really
matter because uh it's it all comes down
to a pawn move
king to f4 we have king to f2 and now uh
white seems to have the opposition but
black has the pawn move
c4 and now uh everything white plays
loses so morphic capture doesn't really
matter otherwise you just capture
capture
so the captures on c5 c4 creating a pass
pawn for morphe but it doesn't matter
king captures and now if pawn push you
are
in time to stop the pawn king e2 by
morphe king d4 we have king to f3
and now captures on c4 king e4 king b4
captures and captures here morphy played
king to d4
and of course love intel played king to
b4 and it was in this position on
59 that paul charles murphy resigned the
game and a second victory in the match
for yohanyakubental
where you know it was really really
crazy so uh morphe had a winning
position
and then he didn't and then he wanted to
win either way and then he lost
something that happens to all of us uh
regardless of who we are and how good we
are at
chess and uh here of course it's
completely winning for black if you
don't believe me i'm going to show you
why
uh well uh of course black just wants
the queen the pawn and there is no way
for white to stop it
white could stop it if black would just
allow the king to reach the pawn but
black will just
follow the white king king here king
here take away all of these squares from
the white king and then queen the pawn
so it's it's a very easy win
and you might be thinking uh as some
people
sometimes comment like why are you
showing us games like this we like to
see games where morphe sacrifices
everything and just uh you know wins and
uh you know he's the best well
of course i mean i enjoy games like that
as well uh but it wouldn't do justice
to the saga i mean uh we need to show uh
all the games like if it's a complete
snooze fest i'm gonna skip it but this
wasn't i mean
i enjoyed this uh uh rather you know
uh a peculiar pawn push and you know
one day when this whole situation in the
world clears up and you're uh
back with your friends at the bar in the
library they're gonna be saying like oh
that morphe he was like uh
you know total beast he just obliterated
everyone and you're just gonna be like
yeah but remember
remember that game eight against low
intel in london in 1858 where he made
the pawn push on the wrong side of the
board and you know it just leads to
a higher quality conver conversation if
we
also cover games like this uh so yeah
uh once again that's uh the game i do
hope you enjoyed it uh i would like to
thank uh crossing kotoro david kimura
christopher reynolds
uh andres weidinga and ivy ivy uh made a
contribution with a
special message because last year uh on
her uh one year anniversary with douglas
uh he made a contribution to a channel
with a shout out to her and now she
makes a contribute contribution with a
shout out for douglas
saying douglas ivy is your checkmate for
life and
she ordered you a gift from my merch
shop that will uh
arrive very very soon hopefully if they
don't mess something up
so yeah thank you ivy thank you everyone
and uh yeah once again i do hope you
enjoyed it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the good
stuff the morphe saga checking up on
your wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so thank you all i will see you
soon and have an excellent rest of your
day